so we're here in SoHo Square London and
we're going to see if people can receive
our serve for 100 pounds
Oh my days you probably come to the
wrong part you've got a lot of good
players here so we've heard big talk
from this park
that's crazy though I didn't even get a
chance you're leaving a lot of space
over there
oh okay for a big forehand I think
that's hard to play
I don't play I just want to try it might
be an advantage it might not but it's
okay
all right let's see if the force is with
me on this one let's go okay you're
standing over there
oh
have you played before yeah all right
okay
oh
Infinity there right yeah let's see your
video what's your strongest side back
hand I think so yeah
[Music]
oh wow that's right
oh
oh come on you can do it
oh good luck okay thank you so much oh
yeah I am a good player I need the luck
in support from audience okay
come on
amazing thank you so much if you receive
us so if you get 100 pounds
deal we've got our next challenge here
look at this grip just had some money
ready
one of the best yes
oh
I took it before I even passed
I need to prepare myself you know you've
got to see where the ball is coming
people are in the pool
you ready I think so
what's your name okay nice to meet you
I know
I will try to make a point
oh so much spin you're not gonna give me
a hint I'm not gonna give you a hint
oh
at least you touched it I'll go change
my t-shirt and come back yeah all right
Joanna good luck I'm gonna try new sir
that's the world's fastest serve for you
guys keep the channel going yeah we will
thank you thanks for coming
it was today not all here for us no so
what's your name Joseph nice to meet you
nice to meet you well I watched you guys
for three years oh really yeah yeah like
you and a meal or not like and Otto of
course let's hope he can get it surprise
me
[Music]
uh relax okay that's my bad last one was
close good luck cheers mate
oh I had to go for a short one because
he was standing all the way back there
how confident are you feeling
oh that is hard it's a spin it's a spin
I got a good position
foreign
[Music]
that was one of the closest ones so far
oh
the track
thank you very impressive
uh infinity
we'll see one of ourselves okay okay
okay he has a good racket I got a
feeling he's gonna rip it oh
thank you thank you if you didn't come
to the body yeah we just got returnable
yeah yeah you think you're gonna do it
um I've been all right maybe
[Music]
that's amazing congratulations thank you
for my YouTube now is that yeah
you can make sure you go and subscribe
thank you guys right me and the missus
are going to get pissed
oh this is serious it spins like this
you have to pull it up
okay now foreign
wait give me a moment okay yeah take
your time are you from Norway Finland
Finland okay Denmark nice Finland will
win
hold the rocket like that oh cool
I had to do it what's your name Julia
Julia
it's called pongfinity And subscribe on
YouTube thank you have you played before
never
oh it just kicked
thank you thank you that was good let's
hear some cheer for Dimitri
I will do it now I will do it now
okay I don't even know which hand no
strategy I'm just gonna whack it
oh okay
[Music]
thank you so much nice thank you it's
going very well but what's the strategy
contract
as long as you know the theory
so the the master of counteraction how
do you counteract this thing who knows
who knows
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right
[Music]
have a nice weekend the next person that
receives the serve will be the last
Challenger
[Music]
[Applause]
send it
oh that wasn't really close
Oh my days there's so many people we
can't take everybody
if you get them all you'll get to go
next three point one four one five nine
two six five three five eight nine seven
nine three two three I thought you said
80. 18. oh
I'm just certain way he's not standing
let's try it
Hollow I guess that's impressive you're
giving me a what is this
Shrek's adventure it's Shrek vs Alexis
Sanchez we'll have you both you go first
we'll do it for Alexis Sanchez yeah
oh oh
all right last one
inshallah
I want to thank my mom
I made it out I made it out subscribe to
punkfinity
it's actually good and let us know in
the comments where you want us to do
this challenge next and we'll be there